greetings you bad [__] it's
Thursday baby what a better way the
[__] end the day sparklingly uncle
Joey just catching up on what the [__]
is going on here
the sun's out the birds are chirping but
more importantly you're slinging dick
and giving our [__] chopsticks you
understand me oh [__] is right I got
three different types of weed today I
got death deadly and deadly uh you
understand me and what a smoke all three
of them let you know what the [__] is
crackalacking hand
oh [__] you [__] wallet you got
it
oh [__] look at uncle Joey looking like
LOI
lui [__] L'Amour look at the hairdo
is on [__] fire you understand me I'm
four days away from shooting the
[__] Netflix special thanks to
you guys I'm [__] fired up I'm ready
to stab my [__] you understand
me I'm like Roseanne without the [__]
ambien [__] ambien what the [__] is
wrong with you talking [__] and then you
blame it on me I've even talked [__]
[__] digging to your nutsack and tell
people the truth you just talked some
shaking [__] up you won't do it again
but you know where they're blaming it on
ambien people making dinners on ambien
suck my dick all right everybody got a
[__] story if you stick to this you
won't talk no [__] garbage nobody
will be tip-top Magoo [__] like
I said I got three different types of
wheat this I got [__] son Center boy
that's the best right there the [__]
cake I got this Disneyland this smells
like a woman's [__] sweaty vag she
went to [__] yoga for 30 minutes
smells tremendous and then you got this
[__] sativa I know what this is but
it's [__] tremendous you know I don't
smoke [__] sativas it's a green crack
oh [__] oh [__] let's burn some white
look at it let's burn some who looks at
Budds that's for [__] amateurs I
burned buds I'm a [__] bud arsonist I
smoked some of this reefer all these
people come over look at these pictures
of buds on what do you got a [__] Bud
Museum I don't see none that [__] if you
ain't sparking I ain't coming over you
know [__] it
ah tremendous a little Disneyland a
little [__] whatever green crack and
was set for the rest of the afternoon I
got school more my daughter
I got a few spots tonight The Improv
I'll be a couple different [__]
places tonight just working on the 28th
baby that's it that's all we're worried
about right now don't give a [__] about
next week I don't give a [__] about my
date and you don't give a [__] about
nothing all were worried about his
Monday night in Las Vegas my brother
George is coming [__] Lee syat scum
and obese Pookie's coming K Quigley's
come and Steve some mom's coming Danny
Brown will be there making an appearance
my brother job I mean it's gonna be
[__] tremendous I'm with family i'm
with good [__] hands and i feel good
thanks to you guys because without you
guys I never got see understand you guys
stayed on Netflix and told them what the
[__] was running things and they finally
listened to you that's why I love you
[__] with all my heart without
you guys I'd have nothing I'm with you
you're with me and these punk-ass
[__] wanna be with us showing up with
[__] ham be on tweets and [__] get
your [__] together you're 65 [__]
years old I'm 55 I'm still tailing
[__] I shot the Kennedys why
because you claim responsibility for
everything who gives a [__]
claimed responsibility listen when I got
quarter the [__] convicted of the
[__] kidnapping I could've beat it
cuz I went to the dentist that morning
they shot me with that fog but you know
what to do a little time to take care of
all this [__] I had done before all the
bad [__] I had done would go away what
if you were to let me loose I would have
done I would have kidnapped somebody
else and this time I'm full of Polly
shot him and I wouldn't be in the place
I am today so do you understand you
gotta live up to your [__] things if
you [__] up you [__] up they no big
deal but these people that are in their
[__] lives it's no big deal
who is gonna cave a debt than [__] me
nobody nobody's gonna cave a debt than
me right there done felonies nobody
wants to hire you know what I don't give
a [__] tell em I did you got more heart
than the [__] guy that's eligible for
the [__] job he's I'm saying listen I
got that back in the seventh grade I'm
no [__] genius
I talk to people today I wonder how they
[__] they walk
and I'm a [__] be honest if I'm a [__]
and they're a [__] idiot how the [__]
yeah it's it's unbearable but anyway who
gives a [__] about that [__] Joey let's
smoke some [__] reefer I came to get
down I came to get down so get on your
feet and jump around what did you do to
Claire what did you do to conditioning
you know me dawg have you [__]
training before the everything is
disciplined for the stand-up special I'm
not gonna get this chance again I'm 55
and I was in the grave and God knows
whether you're [__] for this but
every day I wake up and I go today is my
[__] lucky day today is the day I'm
gonna let these [__] know I
think to suck my dick you understand
because at the end of that's all you
want for all of them to suck your dick
everybody's wrong your [__] guidance
counselor you [__] the prison shrink
they were all [__] along I'm still
ticking [__] anyway don't get me
[__] fired up it's only 4:00 in the
afternoon I still haven't had my [__]
tempo chur you know say what we smoking
now oh [__] let's try this mini lamp and
let's end this [__] with a
hooter now again I want to thank you
people for believing Uncle Joe you
believed in me guys and that's big and I
believe in you went together we got
something I didn't show up with [__]
cool pie don't listen I show up [__]
solo whether you like me and I don't
give a [__] I don't mean no harm to show
them I'm a [__] savage and eat just
like you [__] Joey what's with
the hit beat
let's [__] spark
did you see my I get a little twisted to
the side I like that when a bottle when
a [__] pipe make sure I look for the
other side that's when you know that
roof is [__] working and I'm saying
so I'm taping Monday I'm taking a couple
weeks off from going down to Disneyland
with my wife
merci graduates pre-k I'm gonna take a
little and one day I'm gonna hang out
down there for two days and then I come
back and I go to the Colusa casino what
we've done the next six weeks the
[__] dedicated to right in the
beginning of the [__] book that's the
next step so you guys could have a book
early next [__] year we get this out
of the way with all the [__] juicy
details on what the [__] happened who
got stabbed who then gets that then
number two August we go back on the road
Kansas City Nashville Boston you know
you [__] name it [__] in Washington
DC Philadelphia you got [__] West Palm
Beach you got we got a whole bunch of
[__] dates for you people every other
week because you know me I'm trying to
be a [__] dad here and beside that
you know I love your [__] I
just wanna touch base with you you're
gonna have you
you got your podcast with a weekly up my
man send and Donovan [__] Patton a
dear friend of mine in fact I'm gonna
see him tonight and then you'll have
your bike gassed Monday morning even
though or [__] Las Vegas that's how
we roll i'ma talk to you people from the
[__] heart on that podcast well
besides that we're done we got nice and
high
we did a couple to two looters but [__]
it you can't walk let's finish this [__]
in this is the last mission and how we
do it baby
I ain't doing no more edibles I'm done I
haven't done an added bonus uh-huh I did
a couple more [__] Sunday but anyway
way that it was like whatever but I'm
done no more that [__] I lost 33 pounds
we're gonna go for [__] 265 and see
how big the head looks and then keep
lowering the [__] weights that's it
that's all you can do people trying to
get healthy every [__] day it's like
a ham be a dad hang out with you
[__] hopefully don't [__] 70
follow me and you gotta keep the [__]
my lugia step [__] hard too that's
another thing so that's a complete
different situation underneath to get
into that you know I love your mother
[__] with all my heart I figured i
Tubbs basically you let you know we're
good for God Monday night I ain't gonna
let you down you've been [__] with me
for [__] years and we're all blue
[__] cow that's why yeah that's why I
like you you like me we don't [__]
around but Monday I'm gonna deliver the
goods for you [__] for always
being that funcle' Joey it's Wendy here
ouki Spooky's coming because uh Ralphie
promised her a trip to Vegas he died
before you could fulfill that trip and
since I want morale free spirit there I
[__] Mookie Spooky's coming so we're
gonna have a good time I'm happy I'm
around family ticket links are still
popping up if you want to get tickets
and show up you know you [__] family
with the church I think Eddie Torres is
showing up and random Bozzio we got some
[__] family going deep down there so I
love you [__] thank you for
checking in you got the podcast you got
everything I'll be on Twitter the mom
wanna stay black have a great weekend
and we'll [__] transmit live from Las
Vegas on Sunday